hi guys sci-fi recapped here before we
start morning
spoilers ahead today i'm gonna explain a
2016 american fantasy and action movie
called warcraft
the movie begins with durotan a
chieftain of the frostwolf clan and his
pregnant wife drakka laying down while
discussing the name of their future son
then durotan is seen meeting other orc
clans they all have been summoned by
goldon who is also an orc leader he is
checking preparations for battle while
accompanied by a female half orc garona
who acts as his translator to other
races
a caged prisoner tells garona to spare
her child but goldon refuses saying the
fuel for my magic is life as he intends
to drain all lives out of the prisoners
bodies to fuel his green death magic
called the fell
he aims to provide enough magic to build
a portal connecting his world to another
world called azeroth in order to conquer
it but at the moment he only has enough
prisoners to fuel magic to send a
warband consisting of strongest orc
warriors
their immediate purpose is to collect
more prisoners from azeroth to give
supply to bigger magic to open the
portal permanently
durotan his wife his second in command
orgrim and his clan enter the portal
draka feels pain after passing through
the portal and gives birth by the aid of
goldon despite other orcs objections
the baby is dying but goldon drains the
life of a nearby deer and uses his fel
magic to revive the baby announcing him
to the war band as their newest addition
of warrior
in azeroth we see anduin lotar one of
the king's most trusted warriors
inspecting dwarfs works in ironforge he
observes a newly invented mechanical gun
called a boomstick before he thoroughly
inspects it a messenger delivers a
letter saying one of his garrisons has
been attacked and he is needed by the
king's castle immediately he goes to
stormwind meets a prisoner named khadgar
who fails to cast a spell to attack him
lotar notices a strange mark on
khadgar's arm called kirin tormark
khadgar explains he used to be a
guardian novitiate who has a sacred duty
to protect the realm from any danger but
renounced his vow
he asks to examine the body of the slain
soldiers because it may contain the
secret to the attacks
he is surprised when a faded green light
pops out from one of the bodies and
recommends summoning the guardian
himself
lotar warns that the guardian is only
summoned by the king lane wren so they
ride to his castle
there lodar also meets with his sister
who is also the king's wife lady terrier
wren and his son callum
king lane agrees to call the guardian
after learning about the threat and
instructs lotar and khadgar to karatzan
stronghold to meet medivh the guardian
after giving away his blue ring as a
message to medivh
in karatsan a stronghold protected by
white magic of the guardian they are
greeted by morose
he says the guardian is happy to see
lotar and walks him to the guardian on
the top of the tower while khadgar takes
a look around the guardians library he
notices a mysterious figure appearing
nearby him but disappears into the
bookshelf
while searching for it his kirin tor
mark glows brightly upon a particular
book which he takes
but the guardian suddenly catches and
attacks him until he mentions about the
fel a magic that feeds on life itself
medivh then transports himself along
with lotar and khadgar directly to king
lane in stormwind reports from the
citizens said they were attacked by
monsters some kind of beasts
lotar tells them that they need
prisoners to dig more information even
core would tell them something but king
lane responds that they do not know the
danger they are in
lotar medivh khadgar and a small team of
soldiers go to l when forced to scout
possible tracks of enemies they find
traces of fel magic as green glows on
the trees
then they are ambushed by the orc clan
led by durotan with casualties on both
sides
lotar informs that the orcs are much
stronger so do not try to outpower them
but use smart moves instead
he manages to cut the hand of blackhand
the warchief fork
khadgar uses his magical ability to help
defend himself and medivh while medivh
summons his even bigger magic to drain
the fel magic out of the orcs the
frostwolf forks including durotan and
orgrim do not have traces of fel magic
in them so they can escape the humans
meet garona who also speaks human
language and hold her captive and learn
from her that orcs are planning to take
on their world and need prisoners to
feed the fel magic
she says that they come through a great
green gate powered by the fel
in the orc camp black hand is judged
before gul'dan because escaping battles
is not considered honorable for orcs but
durotan interrupts he explains that the
enemy's warlock uses fel magic against
them but goldon does not buy it as he
believes that only he can control fel
magic durotan begins to doubt the fell
medivh secretly questions garona in
prison she explains that the gate is
shown to gold on by a demon then medivh
disappears as other people enter her
cell
the queen offers her a drink and a
chance to live freely and empathizes
with garona
then varona lotar and khadgar go into
the woods to spy on the great gate
at night they exchange their tragic
backstories by the campfire and begin to
empathize with each other garona
explains that the green magic needs life
like a fire needs wood all of the orcs
are planned to arrive at azeroth
following the already arrived war band
when lotar rides ahead to discuss
strategies in advance with king lane
barona and khadgar surprisingly meet
durotan asking them to deliver a message
that he wants to meet with the human
chieftain
in stormwind king lane gathers with all
other races in azeroth to discuss the
threat but they do not want to help
supporting the attack as they are busy
with their own lives garona delivers
durotan's message to the king
king lane deduces that durotan is truly
terrified of the fell and he cannot
overcome the problem alone so he asks
for help although lotar is against the
idea of meeting durotan king lane is
convinced by garona's depiction of
durotan saying durotan wants to protect
his clan and that the fell is also his
enemy the queen gives a blade to garona
to defend herself and to earn her trust
the guardian is seen at khadgar's room
dismissing all of khadgar's research
about the felon burning all of it he
says he will deal with the fell himself
and khadgar's help is not needed khadgar
manages to hide one of the papers of his
research in his robe which is not burned
by medivh the clue says something about
a dark portal and a name elodie
despite the objection of orgrim one of
durotan's trusted people durotan still
meets with lane to unite the frost wolf
clan and the humans against goldon but
suddenly the group is ambushed by
blackhand which labels durotan as a
traitor the humans retreat and medivh's
help comes even though it is too late
he forms an impenetrable magical barrier
to protect the humans from the orc
forces but callan and some soldiers are
separated by the barrier lotar sees
callan killed by black hand unable to
pass through the barrier to save him
garona and khadgar find medivh on top of
the cliff knocked unconscious and take
him to karatsen to heal
but khadgar notices a green light from
medivh's eyes and deduces that he is
somehow involved in the fel magic
khadgar rushes from karate immediately
saying they need the help of kirin tor
durotan is once again threatened by
black hand but he bargains that he will
submit to goldon's plans if blackhand
spares his people durotan instructs
stroka to leave with their son who he
names goel orgrim speaks with goldon
saying that durotan has poisoned the
whole frostwolf clan against the green
magic
meanwhile kodgar meets with the kirin
tor and although they despise him they
allow him to meet with elodie a
protector entity just like the guardian
olodi tells him that medivh is consumed
by the fel magic and cannot control it
then she disappears
back in karatzan moroze helps medivh to
recover but medivh reveals that he is
consumed by the fell and drains moreoz
life out of his body the king is
agonizing over his options in the
defense position but lotar suggests
throwing everything they have to close
the magic gate and make at the top of
their priorities medivh suddenly appears
and lotar expresses his anger at him for
indirectly killing his son king lane
sends lotar to a cell to calm him down
garona comes to lotar at the cell
informing that the king agrees to
assault the gay
lotar tells her that she and other
people should not trust medivh and he
prefers garona stays with him so she
would not get hurt but she refuses
she goes to battle with king lane and
other troops with medivh claiming he
will join them later because he needs to
prepare some things first in karatsan
khadgar then arrives at stormwind and
rescues lotar from his cell
although lotar insists on following the
king khadgar convinces him to stop
medivh so that the whole azeroth realm
stays safe
drakka brings goel to the river and let
the water carry him away and then she
gets killed like the other frostwolf
clan durotan challenges goldon to a
makoro tradition a duel to the death for
leadership of the orcs which goldan
accepts
then the magic portal is already opening
through the help of medivh who is now
slowly becoming a demon
seeing the portal goldon wants to
quickly finish the challenge but
blackhand urges him to honor the
tradition and stays fighting he then
cheats by draining the life out of
durotan which invokes anger from other
orcs
after durotan and several rebellious
orcs die guldan assembles the warband to
face incoming attack from king lane and
the humans a great battle ensues between
them
lotar and khadgar arrive at karatsan and
witness medivh reciting the incantation
to open the portal to transfer more orcs
to azeroth the golem medivh builds also
comes to life in a tax lotar then lotar
gets the idea to cut off his head after
defeating the golem khadgar tells him to
distract medivh so he cannot recite the
incantation to keep the portal open then
lotar calls out to medivh believing his
good self is still inside the demon
entity just when medivh is about to
attack lotar again the headless golem
falls on top of him due to khadgar's
enchantment khadgar directly attacks the
demon and tries hard to not be consumed
by the fel magic
lohtar assures him that he can do it and
when he finally succeeds medivh is back
again in human form reciting a spell to
open a portal directly to stormwind
while dying in the middle of the battle
king lane sees the portal to stormwind
and is glad that the guardian is finally
helping them he instructs his army
including garona to form a defense line
around the portal and free the prisoners
allowing the prisoners to safely get
through the portal but then medivh dies
and the portal closes so the orcs are
able to attack them from behind the
portal black hand is quickly approaching
king lane to take the honor of killing
the king but king lane instructs garona
to kill him because it will do no good
if they are both dead by killing the
king garona earns the respect of the
orcs and is able to carve away for
achieving peace between humans and orcs
lotar arrives in the middle of the
battle and rescues king lane's body and
helps fight the remaining orcs after he
gets knocked out he wakes up in the
middle of the makora tradition organized
by black hand to duel with him
he is given king lane sword as a weapon
and he easily defeats black hand with
one strike the orcs respect him although
goldan instructs them to kill him but
garona convinces that if bulldog kills
lowtar he is not honoring the sacred
tradition and no orc will follow him
anymore lotar gets away with the king's
body after noticing garona's blade on
the king's neck assuming she is a
traitor during lane's funeral all races
of azeroth finally unite and proclaim an
alliance against the orcs they support
lotar as the leader of the alliance
meanwhile on the river goel is found by
humans
subscribe to watch more videos like this
turn on notifications and leave a like
to help the channel out thank you for
watching